this thing is called the infinite
machines P1 but I'm going to call it the
Cyber scooter for obvious reasons so I
think clearly the design is inspired by
the cybertruck right it's got these
sharp angles it's got aluminum and steel
also way I think these lights are
integrated up front looks pretty sick
especially at night it's got blinkers
and a brake light here at the back but
there's also a carplay screen up at the
front that'll show you everything plus a
slot for your phone right here also a
horn but most importantly this is fully
electric just like the actual cyber Tru
and surprisingly modular this block down
here is actually the battery and it's
fully removable and replaceable and on a
full charge that'll get you 70 M of
range which means that the part you're
sitting on is not battery it's actually
storage and where you plug it in so this
thing has three modes fast faster and
fastest and there's a red boost button
under this flap that gets you to your
top speed of 55 mph as fast as possible
so just like the Cyber Tru this thing is
not out yet and it'll be pretty pricey
around 10K when it comes out later but
yeah this might be better in the city
for a lot of people than any truck